it's an easy excuse for Democrats to
blame Trump for the crisis on the border
there is no shocking the conscience of
Trump voters because this is what he
promised that he would hurt the right
people and so those images that shocked
us and shocked anyone with decent
humanity it's the Roman Colosseum right
now as we speak there are expecting
mothers nursing moms elderly folks
vulnerable populations being held in
detention unnecessarily doing permanent
damage to children literally Donald
Trump's Alana administration reports are
talking about the permanent damage
they're doing to kids he's trying to
terrorize these immigrant families he
wants to intimidate immigrant families
and to kill them from participating in
American life he has to create chaos
create a problem and then try and be the
hero that somehow temporarily solves it
but many Democrats are experiencing a
dramatic shift in their thinking on the
issue according to a new poll in January
only 23 percent said there was a crisis
now it's 70 percent an astonishing 47
point shift and to think just months ago
they viciously mocked Trump for calling
the situation at the border a crisis
this president just used the backdrop of
the Oval Office to manufacture a crisis
President must stop holding American
people hostage but to stop manufacturing
a crisis the crisis on the border is a
manufactured crisis they are engaging in
what I would call manufactured moral
crisis its so-called crisis at the
border is faked this is a crisis of his
own making because it was a campaign
pledge it's the president we don't need
to create artificial crises we have
enough real crises tonight the president
tries to sell a crisis that the facts
tell us does not exist all of this this
whole mess is manufactured it's a
manufactured crisis a non crisis at the
border that's really not fooling anybody
this shutdown that he caused by creating
a phony crisis actually did cause one
danger after another but no sign of the
no emergency that the president has been
talking about as a matter of fact it's
pretty tranquil down here
fake manufactured artificial the only
reason that the Democrats think it's a
crisis now jesse is because they figured
out how to benefit politically from it
yeah I mean I want to have a
conversation actually with Juan about
this just to see his thinking because I
need to know what is the plan and we're
gonna forget about the fact that you
know it became a crisis after six months
we're gonna forget the fact that we
warned that this was going to happen
that we couldn't handle this amount of
illegal alien families that these are
record amounts of illegal alien failing
bees coming in and we don't have the
infrastructure of facilities to handle
it well put that aside we'll start fresh
one if an adult male from Central
America comes to the border with a minor
and they see a Border Patrol agent and
they just walk right up what is the plan
to deal with them at the moment we send
them Bennett what is your plan oh I was
it I thought you meant what no no what
is the plan what is your plan to deal
with it well somehow do you have someone
is that a port of any I'm not talking
about that I'm talking about the match
the Rio Grande well thanks for this
country with a minor right how would you
think the best way to handle and process
they are applying for asylum we have a
law in the country that says you were
allowed to apply for a song okay but
then what would you do it so you don't
know who they are they don't have IDs
you don't know if they're related how do
you make sure she's not being trafficked
how do you know they're even related I
don't know the answer to that but I
guess that what you do is if you're the
border patrol officer you ask questions
and also where do you ask those
questions what do you mean you have to
you would sit and talk in the middle of
the hot geyser no Jesse you write this
you take them to a facility yes right
okay so you're you believe we need to
take them to a facility absolutely and
then you don't ask them questions
together you have to separate them to
make sure their story's real we don't
know that's where you briefly separate
them and then hold them in its attention
facility and then once you ask them
questions and you think you're gonna a
certain anything what do you do with
them next well if they're a family I
think then you have to if they've
applied for asylum you begin the asylum
process at the moment and then what's
the process then what do you mean what
you it's all what do you do with the
well what do you physically do with them
well at the moment what we do is we
detain people for a time and then we let
them go okay so you just let them go
into the interior of the country because
people come back for those hearings
people want you just for your sanity
talk to voters you let them talk to the
agents and then you release them into
the interior of the country and you wait
for an asylum hearing correct correct
that's exactly what you agreed with the
whole process I think you just missed a
lot of news because Trump in fact has
now limited of applications for sound
told people to wait in Mexico is you
must have missed the word of news one I
can't believe you just agree with the
president no I I just think it's this
exact policy let me just say this one
Trump exacerbated a difficult situation
there was never an invasion by any
military force coming across that border
which is what he was saying now it's a
humanitarian crisis that's why
Dagan the numbers have gone up in terms
of Democrats saying we have to deal
we've seen the pictures you've seen the
picture of that man his daughter I think
the pictures a Pelosi got on the horn
and sent out a Talking Points Memo to
all those members of the media who
called it fake and manufactured and said
you idiots we need to fund that
humanitarian relation why did they
change their tune so rapidly because
they realize that they were disgusting
hypocrites
I remember how this started because
we've been doing this show for six
months or seven months began with the
incitement of caravans with a activist
push to encourage the use of children as
props in a you know in a strategy to
overrun a system that was a previously
run by Obama all those pictures of kids
in cages from Obama's time never mind
but people did die during that and while
they died all those people said there
was no crisis so I don't like when
they're talking about the suffering and
the drowning that happened now that
makes me sick because those people were
laughing when people were talking about
about
prices they lost their seat at the table
literally laughing yeah and and look I
mean you've got a situation here where
they've known what situation is it's not
as though anybody just suddenly became
aware of it
the reason the president was elected was
because Americans recognize the problem
and we care about it because
specifically that dad and that little
girl who died had been encouraged to
exactly because of the rhetoric that we
hear about free health care and it's
sanctuary cities that maybe they would
have been safer at home for a period of
time but the people moving through
because of the encouragement of liberal
rhetoric of what Gavin Newsom saying
about what Obama was saying at the time
is is having them take undertake these
adventures that end up being very
dangerous now we know apparently that
people are being little kids are being
rented out on the on the southern side
of the border for people to bring them
over it facilitates sex trafficking and
human trafficking and pain and suffering
all of this rhetoric just because of the
politics of the Democrats this is what
we're opposed to the first people hurt
are the migrants who are going to come
here and be abandoned by system that's
going to collapse like the one that
they're fleeing from that's why we're
that they're trying to escape a very
difficult situation in South America and
bring their children here for greater
opportunity in the Rio Grande that's not
what we've been in terms of the burden
on the United States Milt Friedman the
economist once said you can't have open
borders and a welfare state